why does a woman need a man that's what
I mean they just don't realize it yet
because you try surviving on your own
without a man you cannot wake up in the
morning and go through your whole day
without having to rely on a man for
something like what
about everything around us wherever you
go you get your petrol wherever you go
and get the bus whether you the the the
clothes that you wear in the shop the
designer you cannot get through life
without a man man built the world
like they they do all of the hard jobs
in society everything that makes the
infrastructure run I'm not saying we
don't need men that's not my view at all
but I just feel like
this is what this is like that term left
over I feel like the things you're
saying and the over Reliance on men
that's what perpetuates that view
because it makes it seem like a woman
literally can't survive without a man
and I feel like you're linking that like
one thing you mentioned earlier you said
that there's a link between divorce
rates and um when women were able to get
access to birth control and I feel like
in terms of marriage like when you're
when you're equating marriage with
that's when a woman's gonna have kids
and she's gonna take some of the man's
income in that sense I feel like
um I've lost my point now I forgot what
I said a lot of I feel like
there's a lot of feelings is there any
do you come from a place of logic or is
this all feeling
what do you think is feeling like what
do you think is feeling no could you say
I feel like I feel like I feel like so I
was just wondering if you're saying that
I do want me to say it no no I don't
know I'm is it all feeling if you tell
me your feeling then I don't think it's
feeling this is what I mean I feel like
women have what do you want me to say
sorry
okay okay so
um yeah from what you said about divorce
rates and birth control I feel like
that's where women have gained power in
terms of
they don't neces they're not burdened
financially
um so they're free to leave they're free
to leave marriages and I feel like
that's another reason why I said
um I feel like our generation is
changing so women are we are becoming
more independent because it's not the
same like
no offense but like to compare to now
and 30 years ago the amount of women
that are educated and then because
they're more educated they have access
to higher paying roles and more debt
though they have more debt okay okay but
that's I would say what leaves women in
a bad place financially is kids and
because we have access to birth control
now that's what I mean by I feel like we
have power and I wouldn't go to the
extreme of saying a woman needs a man
but I wouldn't also go to the extreme of
saying a woman can't live without a man
I feel like there's an in-between
but you shouldn't use extremes I think
it's extremely easy to say that
all right then if he was young
and then you had a child and then you
say you didn't need the man you'd be all
right raising a child on your own
because you wouldn't need a man
you just got your child
whereas you might not think that you
need a man when you've got a child but
actually you do but you won't realize
that until you see the consequences
through your life and through your
child's life because when women have
children it's all right to say I'm going
to leave the marriage because you're
going to leave the marriage with the
child the house the car his money you
don't have to work again
so when you're saying that women have
the power from like way back when
because I'm the oldest so way back when
in my day
I wanted when I had to go to um
when you go to school and they say what
do you want to do when you grow up and
you go and see the officer
two things I wanted to be either a
housewife or a lorry driver
and she told me those are the two most
stupid things she ever had to come out
that room and all through my life all I
wanted to be was a housewife and all of
my friends thought it was crazy that was
the worst job ever but some of the most
successful couples I know is with the
woman at home because she the man brings
everything in but a confused one as a
young person there's nothing wrong being
a housewife and having your side Hustle
I wouldn't you can have your side hustle
you can have your own business you can
have your own Law Firm you can have
everything like that and still be a
housewife and when young people look at
it like oh there's something wrong being
being a housewife
wait till you're 35 and you're on your
own and there's no man and it's just you
and your pets and then you're gonna
think I've got my degree I've traveled
I've done this I've got my house I've
got my business who are you going to
travel with your old friends your old
female friends because nobody of any
status is going to want to travel with
you especially if you've got children so
you might think that things were
different back in the day but things
were actually better back in the day
because people got married I am one
person I believe until death do you part
you shouldn't be allowed to get divorced
somebody should have to die before you
get divorced because that's what it says
till death do you part and if more
people were into marriage thinking you
know what get counseling let me go and
do this talk to my elders talk to my
parents then get more successful
marriages and it wouldn't seem so bad as
a young person
I agree with you I'm not against
marriage I don't have anything against
marriage but I'm just realistic
um in terms of generation we're in I
feel like that's where a lot of the
things you're saying I disagree
um and another thing that I feel like
you're saying you need a man voice when
you have a child which I understand
because parenting is a two it's for two
people it's not for one person
regardless of if you're a man or a woman
you need two people to parent however I
wouldn't say that a woman needs like
what you're saying about so you're
saying a woman that's 35 she's done a
lot like in terms of financially she's
had a lot of Life Experiences but she's
not with a man you're saying her life is
unsuccessful just because she's not
going back I'm not saying that I'm
saying issue but successful but will she
be satisfied and won't she be lonely or
she won't be lonely what are you gonna
do when it comes to 50 and you're on
your own 60 when you own 70 when you're
on your own and if you intend to be on
your own like say 35 if you can say
right you know what I'm not going to
settle down to my 35 start planning your
pension start planning that when you're
old or you're disabled or you can't
manage yourself who's going to look
after you you might as well start
planning these things ahead because a
lot of people don't look ahead like that
but if you had a husband
and you're married pensions and all them
things so if you're going to be like
enjoying your life now I had my pension
at 18 so I was different I was one of
those early people but you need to start
planning I have a pension early that's
good you need to start planning early
and think about property and not
traveling and things like that then I
can say well if you're going to be on
your own fine but be happy on your own
but can you be happy on your own at 60
70 80. and that's the one thing just to
backwards she's saying up the least
happy group of women is women over the
age of 45 that have that are single and
childless that make over forty seven
thousand dollars per year
but that's not what I'm saying I'm not
advocating for a woman that's childless
and she doesn't have a partner at 40 I'm
just saying just because you don't have
someone at 35 doesn't mean you keep
going to 60 and 70 again go into
extremes I'm 53 that's not extreme no
but you keep mentioning six how can you
remember talking about you keep
mentioning 60 70 that's extreme from 35.
you don't go from you haven't mentioned
okay a woman at 40. but you're jumping
you're jumping years that's what I'm
saying I'm saying just because my point
is to begin with just because you're 35
and you're single doesn't mean you'll be
single at 40 at 60 at 70. but the
problem is at 35 you've lost all the
things that men value that that's the
problem because man